as it needs an overall exam technique
right if you see an example it's got all
these different questions you haven't
got the first one you're like okay this
is taking forever
well I'm just don't be confused about it
don't get bogged down like an exam is
quite a long thing if you spend loads of
time with something early you might get
it out but then you want to have time
that's very relevant so the topic that
we looked in today so that's kind of
look you know you guys get really fun
right five four three two time this is
what this is for it's for identifying
okay which one's am I gonna start with
first I encourage you to start with the
questions that you know you could do
like in you're pretty confident about
them maybe erase or warm up and then you
can have tackles on behind so that's
exactly what I'm going to do I'm gonna
kick off a good question - so we begin
let's get down the important details so
there's a right there
$15 63 that supporter that's good she'll
get 35 hours and that rate and then blue
color she gets up she has two different
rates for the different kinds of
overtime right and I deliberately did it
a little bit different from what I
usually get usually it's time to lock
and then double right that's common but
there's no reason it has to be like that
air receiving times you'll often get
different names depending on the job so
you'll notice her first kind of overtime
is doubled and then her second but if
she goes even further than that is
double time and huf so that means for
instance he if he worked an hour that's
gonna count her pay is gonna count as if
she worked - mm right two times and for
this if she worked an hour every hour
she works after that it's going to be
two point five okay so I'm going to put
them down those important bits of
provision for
okay so find a pay now for a 48-hour
week so I'm going to say equals okay the
first 35 hours are at that global rate
yeah so I'm going to say he is $15 63
and I'm gonna multiply that through by
the first bit just the regular bit 35
but then there's some number of hours
where she'll get double right happy
hours 4 hours right sir the next 4 hours
right that's a she were 13 I know it's
to get it done okay
so 35 hours here I've got now I've got
no I know is how many are left over I
hang up nine more hours right so that
night now is is at two and a half times
right so I'm gonna go two and a half
times those last night out okay now once
I've set that up the rest of that is
just approaching someone really but a
number
1023 and 77 cents that's it was anybody
involved yeah yeah so you had to round
up wall down I guess depending on what
there is here and about so there you go
all years to do is set that up properly
based on reading the question so that's
fine
now let's uh let's go back so the reason
why this is a bit trickier is because
you can see they give you some
information so there's an annual salary
right how'd they say well I said there's
a bonus young but then they do this
classic mathematics general theme of now
comparing that like don't just give me
the answer compare it to something else
what if the bonus had been changed now
this is extra tricky because you can't
simply just deal with the question as if
you can't go directly from 8% bonus to
4% oh okay
well what if you had no bonus like the
question doesn't tell you to do that you
kind of work that out first right so
question one I'm going to say six to one
to one dollars sixty and there's a clue
that tells you in the question there's a
phrase that tells you that how does the
8% already in what's the language very
good you've got a well like a single
word changes the wording that chooses
the meeting of any tightening right so
since that includes the 8% right what
this really is is a hundred eight
percent of way actually learns does that
make sense
hundred and a hundred is the original
and then it's got the other eight
percent so I want you to find five
hundred names
okay do you remember before if I gave
you a base salary like so suppose he was
I mean it's long but supposed to us
50,000 I say okay tell me the bonus
narrow I said you could multiply that by
a hundred a percent
I'm trying to go in the other directions
that's why I divide instead of lots of
money does that make sense okay
so this is going to give me ears a bit
naughty I really should have said what
might happen yeah what's this going to
mean yeah it's the local salad or I'm
using the phrase base salary right it's
like what are you parents not just with
the opposite bonus but we can do a bow
to them so I should put this okay so
let's get a number shall we kill if I
notice the occupation it starts with
five five five five okay I saw that was
I have a working but that sounds about
right
convert that okay so this is the base
salary so now say salary weird metaphor
percent bonus okay so now I'm gonna go
back to have fifty seven whatever and
that's what I'm going to add a four
percent of course that would give you a
new novel which is we get over 64 so
fine okay
so I just want to point out some common
errors that can't be the question like
this this is exactly why I worded it in
this way frequently people will see 8
percent and they'll see that number and
they'll just go 8 percent of that right
8 percent of whatever is already here
but you see why we're not doing them
right the 8 percent is an additional 8%
is already in there that's why a hundred
a Merced is what's gonna tell me how to
work this
get to the bay cellar okay so the base
salary is going to be divided through
them and then there's a secondary step
you think gotta okay alright so there
was some traps and pitfalls there heard
that made sense yes okay please I think
measured after I could have I hope my
work in this little soon
let's help we can question three and
there were movements in today's put it
one works in a factory he's got a $19 20
per hour right now again this is tricky
because again there's a comparison you
notice that there's a young will he earn
more and then there are two options
right there are four 10-hour days or
five eight out of those okay now it's
already gone on to this which one's
better
yeah the five eight-hour days off okay
now I just want to pause for a minute
before we get our calculators out to
talk about anything down right before
you calculate all these big first thing
first the use your intuition to die what
you're doing okay tell me
monetary question for each of these
different options right which one has
him working for longer
and the answer is neither do you see
there is a number of hours right like 4
by 10 is 40 and 5 by 8 is also 4 does
that make sense so now what that tells
you is what we look at these hourly rate
his hourly rate actually doesn't matter
right because it both cases you're only
the same per hour does that make sense
and you're working the same time of
hours so when you calculate that part
you'll end up with the same wage say no
how is the same wage but there is
something that's ticking right the plot
that's different is the it's the
allowance right now the allowance is on
what basis how often do you get that
it's a birthday thing right so being it
the more days you work the more of an
allowance from yeah which does that tell
you will be the better option just buy
it without doing any numbers here
clearly more days will be better because
you'll get an extra $11 70 and extra
days worth of allowance does that make
sense that's not enough to get it so we
do need to break it out just briefly but
at least now you know ok at least an
expecting an answer and when I get to
the end isn't what I expected a lot will
I be able to slice it understand okay
so logical home let's do it so we're
going to be four 10-hour days
what's his pay going to be well again
you've already told me it's 40 hours
times what was the rate again and then I
add on all of that
the allowance is this 1170 number and I
multiply it by for the number of days so
I'm going to say plus 4 times that now
because of the conversation I just have
with you I'm actually very disinterested
in this number you should work it out
you'll get something there you put it in
what I'm interested is the comparison
like so now when I work out five days
I'm still gonna have the same 40 times
19 those 20th stock do you agree with
that like five times think we
established that so that's why you can
see mathematically these parts just
equate right and so when I compare them
with their equivalent it's this other
thing which really makes the difference
and we just discussed you get an extra
days worth of the imbalance in that make
sense so whatever your two numbers are
here and here I'm expecting if you have
all the careful calculations it should
be exactly the Levin dollar seventy
different does that make sense do you
get that can you confirm that in your
gonna so that's how you can create that
option B